le 6 juin rose et Guadalupe briano
Esparza perd la vie en se rendant au
travail sa mort a soulevé le voile sur
son sort il était un demandeur d'asile
recruté clandestinement par le
producteur agricole Jean Lemay c'est pas
normal dans une
société comme la société canadienne des
québécoise qu'on doit vivre une
situation d'esclavagisme moderne tel
qu'on le connaît chez Monsieur
Jean-Denis spécialisé dans la production
laitière Jean Lemay recrute des
immigrants les pairets un salaire
dérisoire selon des plaintes déposées à
la cness T mais surtout il agirait à
titre d'agence de placement en louant
les services de ses employés étrangers à
d'autres entreprises ce qui est
strictement interdit par la loi
qui sont vulnérables d'ailleurs en 2021
Jean-Louis s'est vu retirer le droit de
recruter du personnel à l'étranger par
emploi et développement social Canada
décision rare
pour apprendre des demandeurs d'acide
baby-sitter donc c'est déjà encore plus
vulnérable parce que les travailleurs
agricoles quand il arrive ici arrive
avec un visa de travail sur le muscle
une vraie couleur là pas compliqué il
est très simple là-dessus puis en as pas
moi c'est un autre c'est qu'on sait très
bien que la marionnette en arrière c'est
lui qui a contrôle le ministre de
l'Agriculture renvoie la balle au
ministère du Travail c'est des pratiques
sont tout à fait déplorables puis ma
compréhension le sait que le ministère
du Travail et sur son cas si on veut
pendant ce temps une famille pleure sa
sœur Magdalena s'interroge et elle et sa
famille ont appris la mort de rosé par
l'entremise des journaux
on ne sait rien pourquoi personne n'a
noté la plaque de la voiture dans les
articles le nom du chauffeur n'apparaît
pas pourquoi Jean Lemay n'a jamais
contacté la famille du demandeur d'asile
le gouvernement fédéral doit agir
affirme Michel pilon c'est le problème
du permis fermé ça fait des années qu'on
le dit où on en fédéral il faut abolir
les permis fermés parce que demain matin
c'est un travailleur comme chez Monsieur
Jean Lemay qui avait un permis ouvert il
accepterait pas ces conditions de
travail là Radio-Canada a contacté le
producteur agricole oui monsieur Lemay
Jean-Louis a refusé de parler aux médias
ici Marie-Josée paquet como Radio-Canada
Montréal